[Música]
esta historia arranca cuando tenía siete
años yo vi en el barrio en donde me crié
un mural que rezaba si el reto no te
hace temblar las piernas quizás no es lo
suficientemente grande para ti en ese
momento no entendía lo que estaba
escrito y lo entendí a años después
cuando regrese con mi mejor amigo de
ecuador ha emprendido un proceso en un
tema de siembra de cacao orgánico junto
a pequeños agricultores
lamentablemente juanjo se ha fallecido
seis meses después y no alcanzamos a
terminar esto ocurre un cambio
importante en mi vida y ese
emprendimiento se convierte en una
fundación gracias al apoyo de su familia
una fundación que planteaba ejecutar un
proyecto de desarrollo basado en la
educación
allí participe algunos años y entendí
dos cosas la primera lo efímera que es
la vida nadie tiene comprada su vida no
sabemos si vamos a llegar mañana oa 10
años o 50 años no lo sabemos más nos
vale que empecemos a vivirla y lo
segundo que entendí la importancia de la
educación como la columna vertebral
cualquier proceso de desarrollo que
queramos hacer
eventualmente me cambio aquí todo por
temas de trabajo y allí conozco la
belleza o en donde se basa la mayor
parte de la belleza ecuatoriana volcanes
nevados lagunas yo corría 510 kilómetros
como la mayoría de ustedes supongo
y me inscribió en una carrera y me
inscribió en una carrera que tenía 10 20
50 y 80 km cuando me escribí me dijo el
señor diez y veinte están llenas si es
que quiere cincuenta y ochenta y yo dije
bueno
dame una de cincuenta ya no me había
fijado que estaba estaba escribiendo en
una carrera diez veces más grande lo que
venía corriendo el punto es 15 horas
después la pude acabar pero me quedé con
una gran duda bastante muerto pero con
una gran duda si realmente las personas
evolucionamos cuando enfrentamos a
nuestros miedos y esa duda me lleva seis
meses después a estar corriendo en la
patagonia argentina 160 kilómetros sin
ninguna experiencia en montaña jamás
había estado en la noche en una montaña
pero estaba inscrita en esa carrera y
pretendía correr 160 porque mi cálculo
era bueno si ya correcta 50 serían como
unas tres vueltas más 10 kilómetros más
56 horas después pude acabar esta
carrera más muerto que la inicial de
hecho
permitida quedó aclarada realmente las
personas evolucionamos y crecemos como
personas cuando nos atrevemos a
enfrentar esos límites y un día como nos
pasa a todos buscando cosas maravillosas
yo busqué la carrera más difícil del
mundo
al desierto más caliente en el planeta y
una carrera que planteaba a correr 240
kilómetros con una mochila que pesaba
diez kilos con temperaturas de 58 grados
en el día más o menos 67 grados en la
noche y bueno y yo no había tenido
ninguna experiencia esta carrera la
habían hecho cerca de 29 años y no había
ningún ecuatoriano que le había
intentado y que había acabado entonces
dije yo que no soy un corredor a tiempo
completo la voy a intentar porque
entendí que las personas evolucionamos
cuando enfrentamos a nuestros miedos es
por eso que ocho meses después todo un
entrenamiento estaba en medio del sahara
corriendo viendo qué hacía para salir y
para poder acabar esta carrera el
entrenamiento fue bastante complicado
escuchaba música es bueno yo vivo en
quito y entrenaba en guayaquil con
temperatura bastante fuerte humedad
bastante alta escuchaba música que no me
gustaba corría sin medias corría con con
zapatos más bajos para que se me
revienten los pies semana ampollas y la
capa sea más fuerte porque nosotros
entendíamos qué es lo que iba a
determinar si acabado no esta carrera
eran las ampollas en qué
me van a salir este es un pedazo del
segundo día cuando ya la cosa empezaba a
complicarse
yo me motivaba solo
vuelto
punto
meta tasas sobre las ampollas
para dejar descansar a los talones
y así
así pasaréis que lo que el resto del día
puede ser complicado el plan que la
generaron a salir en vía 3 me salieron
el día 1 este es el día 2 en el día 2 en
la noche me cortaron la piel en los dos
pies porque ya era insoportable me
vendaron completamente yo recién llevaba
80 kilómetros avanzados y me faltaban
160 kilómetros
no tenía idea cómo hacerlo tuve que
resolverlo al siguiente día y la
respuesta fue con coraje con valor paso
a paso día a día reto a reto cada hora
es un reto para mí faltaban cuatro días
más y este no era el punto más
complicado el día más complicado fue en
este día el tercer día cuando me
equivoco el desierto es implacable no
permite errores y me equivoqué y puse la
ración de proteínas en mi maleta en el
bolsillo con las pastillas de alcohol
ese alcohol se evaporó se mezcló con la
proteína cuando probé el batido sabía
gasolina y me quedé con esa duda cinco
tragos después y en ese momento me di
cuenta que me están intoxicando me quite
la maleta me di cuenta del error me tocó
votar medio tarro de agua que no tenía y
la ración equivalente a una hora y media
de comida la cosa se había complicado
horas después vi un alemán que venía
corriendo adelante mío se desplomó los
vasos estaban rotos y estaba sangrando
mezclándose con arena yo estaba en shock
no sabía cómo reaccionar llegó un
español sacó una bengala y la disparó
afortunadamente llegó una mula en el
corte que se lo llevaron yo en ese
momento me quite la maleta la bote a la
arena me sentía a llorar porque en ese
rato había tocado el punto más profundo
quizás de toda mi vida no sabía qué
hacer
llegó una amiga francesa me extendió la
mano me levanto y me acompaña un
kilómetro y seguimos afortunadamente los
siguientes días continúan el mismo ritmo
y llegué al día 6 cuando me convertí en
el primer ecuatoriano en terminar la que
es considerada la carrera más difícil
del mundo luego de 240 kilómetros y como
uno lleva a lo otro yo me pregunte bueno
si ya correcta en el lugar más caliente
porque no correr en el más frío ciudad
y entonces aparece el desafío el desafío
antártida de pretender correr en
efectivamente en el lugar más inhóspito
y más frío del planeta donde no había
pasado nada yo soy un país tropical en
una ciudad tropical jamás he pasado un
invierno jamás había pisado nieve pero
me estaba metiendo en la antártida y
pretendía correr 100 kilómetros un
proceso de entrenamiento realmente
brutal porque nos encontramos en el país
un lugar en donde tenga mucho frío pero
que pueda correr en mi país en ecuador
en en la cima de los volcanes sí pero
tenemos menos 10 grados pero no puedo
correr porque estoy a más de 5.000
metros entonces nos inventamos una
figura y dijimos bueno lo vamos a hacer
esta lo vamos a hacer en una caminadora
metimos una caminadora en una fábrica de
hielo yo me metí yo me metí allí porque
el paisaje no iba a cambiar y me tocaba
correr y me tocaba correr un buen tiempo
acompañando al agua que se convierte en
hielo
este es más o menos un vídeo para que lo
vean más o menos en candado
y
pasados nueve meses de temperaturas muy
complicadas me revisaban esto cada cinco
minutos por esa casa y me desmayé pero
el punto es que llegamos al punto más
inhóspito del planeta
corría allí 16 horas seguidas a
temperaturas en promedio de menos 20
grados el pico más bajo estuvo en menos
27 grados realmente agotador yo yo perdí
a 1000 calorías por hora
ese día perdí 6 kilos es una buena idea
para la dieta de mujeres
pero en un día en un día tenía 6 kilos
menos era realmente brutal el tema no
cambiaba nada el sol nunca se fue porque
no oscurece seis meses yo estuve cuatro
días allí nunca la vi a la noche
realmente el cerebro empieza alocarse
tienes que comer 6.000 calorías para no
perder peso imagínense por día entonces
era una barbaridad afortunadamente pude
terminar esta carrera puede convertir en
el primer ecuatoriano en flamear mi
bandera en el punto más sino aspecto del
planeta ya en el polo sur y convertirme
en una de las 14 personas en el mundo
que hemos hecho que hemos corrido en el
lugar más caliente y más frío del
planeta
a más de 100 kilómetros y como lo uno
lleva a los otros entonces sí ya corre
en lo que está más caliente en el más
frío ahora planteo mis siguientes retos
que está conectado a esto que es no
sirve de nada que consigamos logros si
no nos sirven para aportar a nuestras
comunidades yo he pasado el último año
recorriendo mi país en escuelas y
colegios fiscales conversando con chicos
que van a salir ya a trabajar oa
estudiar que tienen muchas dudas muchas
complicaciones y comparten esta
experiencia motivando los no para que
vayan alzada para que vayan a la
antártida pero si motivándolos para que
tomen retos yo no sé si van a cumplir el
reto pero me encantaría como a todos
ustedes nos encantaría que al menos
cojamos ese coraje interno y nos
atrevamos a intentar cumplir el reto
allí está mi misión de vida y es lo que
estoy haciendo últimamente y
efectivamente mi siguiente reto cuales
me voy a ir al lugar más profundo del
planeta y me voy a ir al lugar más alto
del planeta
el lugar más profundo está en sudáfrica
en una mina los mineros chilenos ustedes
recordarán en el 2010 estuvieron
atrapados a 700 metros debajo de la
tierra
yo voy seis veces más abajo cuatro mil
debajo de la tierra en sudáfrica voy a
intentar a 60 temperaturas no 25 de
media relativa voy a intentar llegar a
la superficie tomaré un vuelo que me
llevará a ecuador para conectarme al
otro punto más cercano al sol que es el
punto más cercana al sol que es la
cumbre del volcán chimborazo esto lo
queremos hacer en una sola instancia en
un solo tramo y bueno ojalá lo podamos
hacer para registrar el récord guinness
ahora para terminar quisiera dejarles
una reflexión y pregunta todos aquí
tenemos límites y todos tenemos dos
opciones la primera acostumbramos
nuestra vida a los límites y seguramente
llegaremos con unos años más y la
segunda entendemos que la vida es
efímera que la evolución nuestra está en
enfrentar nuestros miedos esos miedos
nos van a llevar a conseguir logros y
esos logros deberían servirnos para
aportar a nuestras comunidades la
pregunta está allí todos están en esos
límites y cada uno decide qué hacer con
ellos muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]